tout le monde comment allez-vous
voulait une glace non je ne pouvais pas vous dire
bonjour mon nom est Paul McCartney
voici Ringo Starr voici John Lennon maman
George Harrison les Beatles dans un média
ils ont ouvert la voie depuis les caves un
peu audacieuses de  un projecteur national qu'en est-
il des rapports selon lesquels vous n'êtes
rien d'autre qu'un groupe de presse britannique Elvis
sur - ce n'est pas - j'ai besoin de quelqu'un
pas seulement
cette manie est tellement de pression
qu'il n'y a pas de coupure vous êtes allumé 24
heures sur 24 j'étais comme  chanter l'enfer
parce que je voulais dire que c'était vrai, les
enfants, nous avions tous assez peur, c'était
juste du cirque, la musique n'était pas entendue,
nous avons tous commencé à en avoir marre,
nous ne pouvons pas continuer indéfiniment car pour les petites
vadrouilles propres et elle t'aime nous
cherchiez un nouvel endroit où aller vous étiez
normal et le reste du monde était
fou il évoluait il changeait
et nous avons changé avec lui les Beatles étaient
cette unité vous savez nous nous occupions
vraiment les uns des autres donc c'était comme la force
du  Union nous nous sommes eus  euh et nous avons
apporté cela au top musical des
meilleurs disques du groupe britannique de l'année c'est une
petite chimie magique qui s'est produite
entre nous cela semble plaire à chaque
génération à mesure qu'elle se présente
quand êtes-vous Eric Eric Eric voici
le fermier américain John vous  're John
ouais joe